from Pearl Harbor on the night of
October 23rd
Admiral Nimitz radioed a message to the
Chief of Naval Operations in Washington
DC
the Second Battle of the Philippines had
begun
for the men of the Third Fleet this was
the climax to a battle they had been
waiting for months the men who were over
Saipan in June rom in July allow in
September were moving west
they were hitting hard all over the map
all around the cross
army and navy pliers had pounded
Japanese defenses from one end to the
other but they all parted toward one day
October 19 and one target the
Philippines
the invasion force was protected by our
mighty third and seventh weeks
a hundred thousand GIS didn't know where
they were heading but they knew it would
be the last place the jacks wanted them
to go there were hundreds of islands to
pick from and the enemy couldn't watch
them all it wasn't to be Luzon where we
fought our heroic delaying action at
Bataan and Corregidor it wasn't to be
mindanao where philippine guerrillas
have never ceased fighting instead our
Joint Chiefs of Staff had chosen an
inconspicuous island with a name most
Americans had never heard but overnight
it would be spoken in the same breath
with the Coral Sea Midway and
Guadalcanal Leyte America was ready to
fulfill her promise return to the
Philippines
the men of the 6th army in Philippines
important
liberation of 16 million Filipinos was
on the march led by General MacArthur
and president mas name
back home Americans read the optimistic
headlines and thought the worst was over
but the Navy knew the main event was
still to be fought
this was the day our Navy had been
waiting for
but it was also the day for which the
Japanese High Command had been waiting
for they knew they were sending this
battle fleet against us with the odds as
high and their favor as they would ever
be their supply lines were shorter their
fleet had been resting in home waters
and could be supported by hundreds of
land-based planes taking a goo goo -
whoa
well I'm more of a geek a donee hello
mother
he called aya aya to keep continua gah i
bought some meat news to Tory
in the language of military men our army
was committed to this action
this was the fateful moment of every
invasion when a mighty army stands with
one foot on land and the other in the
sea
knowing this the Japanese were ready to
unfold their master plan rushing pincer
movement of battleships cruisers and
destroyers will navigate the narrow
approaches to the American pitcher
cutting Mikasa off from his supply lines
and destroying naval support and in
addition we have planned another
surprise
before they reach the approaches to
Leyte the Japs lost the important
element of surprise our submarine
searching deep in enemy waters surfaced
right in the middle of the Japanese
fleet broke radio silence to flashback
the report
and that's not all they did they sank
two Japanese cruisers the Navy had eyes
above the sea as well
we knew what was coming
and our carriers lost no time
dispatching a receptionist
laughter power to oncoming Japanese
forces forming defenses ran a carpet of
bombs torpedoes and place a fire and
then under cover of darkness our
destroyers crept into Surikov straight
under the big guns of the [ __ ] southern
force and let go their torpedoes
the pts were there too with more fish
it was a rugged trip through both
straits for the Emperor's invincible
portion but they fought on determined to
break through as the jaws of the pincers
kept closing Admiral Kincaid
had to make a vital decision by 3 a.m.
this southern prong of the [ __ ] concern
was going to be too close to our
beachhead for comfort the Admiral
decided to concentrate his main
firepower down here and hit him from all
sides as they came into the cove
meanwhile Admiral Sprague was holding
his light carrier force here to guard
our right flank
then if everything went right we could
knock out this southern threat in time
to protect our beachhead from their big
battleship task force fighting its way
around Samar Admiral Halsey would be
rushing up to hurl his third fleet
against a new Japanese surprise party
reported bearing down from the north
ready to blast the southern section of a
Tokyo Express were five battleships the
Japs had never expected to face again
the California the West Virginia the
Pennsylvania the Maryland the Tennessee
the old battle wagons that had lain in
muddy humiliation at Pearl Harbor were
waiting for reveille
bearing 273 range one through five open
fire sir
nearly 13 miles and scored a directed
that's American gunnery laying our main
batteries on a moving target in the dead
of night the chips were down for the
heaviest service action of World War two
by 5:00 a.m. the southern enemy force
turned and fled that is hauled the 10
warships which reached the Gulf of Leyte
the bottom of the Gulf while the lower
prong of the enemy pincer was being
smashed the upper prong was closing in
through San Bernardino Street led by
Japan's newest fastest battleships this
force had been funded and straight until
it turned back only to come on again in
one last fanatical attempt to smash
through to our beachhead nothing stood
between them and their objective except
a group of low-speed unarmored baby flat
tops screen by a handful of destroyers
and destroyer escorts Apollo 16 and
14-inch guns of each
were leveled against the light batteries
of our escort vessels never out for but
out got outnumbered outmatched
our jeep carriers radioed for help to
admiral Jose's Third Fleet in the north
Admiral Halsey
had to make a difficult decision should
he go to the rescue and ignore the
surprise from the north should he hold
his position and leave our small force
off Samar to fight overwhelming odds the
Admiral did neither instead he kept the
main units of his powerful command on
its course but dispatched a carrier
group to the Samar battle area
facing the murderous barrage of a [ __ ]
heavyweights at point-blank range these
little shifts fighting a desperate
battle the time used everything in the
book to stay afloat and never stop
firing until the sea cause for the poor
ungrateful people will remember their
name The Gambia Bay the USS for the
Johnston
the sameö be Robin there's his a new and
valiant chapter in our naval history on
the dawn of the third day while the
battle was still raging in the south the
curtain was rising in the north on
another phase of this great naval
engagement sweeping down from Japanese
home waters came this third great enemy
force supported by waves of land-based
bombers dedicated to the imperial
mission of striking the finishing blow
for Hirohito the Japs were clinging on
the board of war their highest stakes
their future as a naval power
and once again our fighting men rose up
to meet the enemy even the man of the
sunken fish brought on from other day
our pilots swarm from more carriers that
the Japs have never seen before
to not be enemy on the sky
last time prophecy
was the Japanese queen
but you can't get them all sometimes we
had to fight fire and Japs at the same
time
some of ours have trouble up there too
but for every one big crippled more
we're taking off
and still they came
a [ __ ] zigzag crazily but there was no
place in the Philippines seen this day
where they could hide from the most
devastating attack ever lost in the
Pacific
I do love a third day every enemy ship
that still had a rudder was doing its
best to turn and run for hope for even
while thousands of Japs were being
fished out of the very waters they had
considered their own private seat our
fleet was hunting down the remnants of
three imperial forces and as night fell
on the last day of battle this was all
that would ever be seen of twenty-four
Japanese warships and four hundred enemy
planes 35 more warship or sinking or
straggling home
or every victory men must die
it was battle smashed trains like these
that told the story of that victory
eloquently for here in this plane
damaged beyond repair an American airman
died at his battle station his shipmates
felt it fitting that he be buried this
way
for now let him be nameless
let him be all the sons of America who
have died for our cause let his death
make that cause all the more precious to
us the living
so end of 1944 but the enemy wounded but
desperately rebuilding his fleet for a
savage defense of his island fortress
our course is set for 1945 warning past
lately and Endora beyond the Philippines
to Japan itself a dangerous foes that
again and again must be brought to
action